no you stop oh no used it oh hi uh hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to let's play the great
work I wasn't expecting you here so
early
actually no I am late because I was out
all day today sorry for that this is the
only chance I've had to record and it's
like five sixteen in the afternoon
something like that okay so where we
left off is I was in a room in this room
in particular that was behind this
walled up area that did not seem to have
anything to it but I'm thinking that
that's not the case wait a minute
something actually can be used on you uh
I've used everything no no no no okay
alright so there's got to be something
in this room worth finding I'm thinking
maybe maybe not I could be wrong here
but why else would there be justice whoa
ha ha oh no oh no oh I broke the game oh
oh oh I see I was supposed to go up okay
ah let me through Oh God whose Oh scared
how did I get out ah scary what's going
on huh let me through let me through let
me through let me through everything
ha ha
oh no I'm caught in between worlds ah
this is what I get for practicing bad
medicine
ok let's um get out of there and try
that again shall we
ha ha I was supposed to go up I Lois
looking down and I was looking at the
lady I was not looking up okay hello
baby
aha there we are that was stupid of me
ha ha ha how did I miss that good thing
I went in between universes I have two
heartbeats you know ok
anyway whatever hello who's up here I
wonder oh I'm so glad that rope was so
well attached to something visible
college that's my old associate Hart
London undetectable awk tight of course
but I found a weak spot in the floor or
find out they hiding from me
Samuel aids is very old and difficult to
read ok then
so that was Samuels note from a while
ago I still don't trust Samuel I don't I
think he's full of octopus excrement
whoo this looks oh it's like really
quiet it's like it's like Oh Mike I've
never had it this quiet in here Misha
ever and it's so well lit why why
hello okay this reminds me a level in
the original amnesia okay this is
disturbing on multiple levels just so
you all know like this should not be
happening something is obviously going
very wrong if there's nothing nothing so
why why why alright maybe the maybe the
monsters caught wind of how awesome I am
and whoa hello
well well well mother oh you can are you
son of a [ __ ] you stupid trolling
troller you mother oh you shut up oh
that is the biggest dick move ever
joke's on you [ __ ] I could probably find
a way to fashion some boxes to get up
there but ow my face is now inserted
into my knees oh good now oh wait no
wait what
I thought the bar went down for a second
well what am i doing then oh man why am
I here what is the point you know what
screw it I'm gonna grab a box and I'm
gonna fashion a way to get up that dare
ladder you think I'm not
oh you think I'm not persistent game I
have gone on Dumber ventures than this
to try and get where I need to be ha ha
I've crossed the world's [ __ ] okay
that's definitely not it maybe I need to
take this ladder and use it elsewhere
if I could get it out of there what I
cannot whoa hey ladder whoa seriously
ladder it's calmed down it's not worth
it okay if I take this ladder
there wasn't like any more openness that
I could go maybe I could find a way over
that fence maybe don't think so
yeah don't look like it doesn't look
like it's gonna happen all right don't
look like it
no ah no okay all right screw this I
don't know what it wants me to do I
don't know why I'm doing it why why how
did I get up here anyway it's not like
Samuel was very trapped to begin with
that one ah had the right idea wrong
application my genius was wasted on this
one ah faster ha ha I'm going to lose
this in between the walls but I don't
care ha ha there we go
am too perfectly for my purposes and oh
yeah oh yeah oh ah broke that game again
how do I keep doing this
ha how do I keep breaking the game you
gotta be kidding me I'm the I'm either
the greatest of the worst game tester
ever in the world because this this is
not right
okay maybe I can scope out a way that
I'm supposed to go like I did befores
yeah oh man ah oh I thought I could jump
off there this is completely ridiculous
I shouldn't be playing this game this
isn't fair to the game developer for Oh
bollocks I can't get back it's got to be
a way to go hang on hang on I'm gonna
find some here there's a way where
there's an i rule what the crown's
little shifty there where there's a wall
suicide is not a way it's not
okay so that solved the problem of me
being stuck so what am I gonna do about
oh maybe oh oh maybe I was supposed to
put the ladder on the block I don't know
come here come with me okay [ __ ] you
ladder I don't know what I'm supposed to
do I'm lending them loss hello baby I'm
Liv Ling Ling Ling Ling dang loss but
maybe if I take that ladder input boxes
under it I don't know I don't know how
should I know there's got to be a
purpose to be up here because the other
way no it can't be that simple it can't
be that simple can it hah oh it can't be
that simple ah
why did the music suddenly get sinister
hang on I have an idea and it's probably
a bad one
but I have one damn it I'm bleeding
through my eyeballs again gotta stop
that it cannot be this simple can--it
you guys see what I'm getting at right
you guys see what I'm you you're you're
picking up the signals I'm laying down a
it can't be can it can it can it can it
be this simple where I would just need
two of these and there's no way it can't
be that simple look at the look at the
forearm strength I got on this bad boy
ah piss ah yes sir
piss more that wasn't the way well then
I don't know I bet I could figure out
some sort of lever mechanism to
repeatedly stack boxes on the end so
they outweigh my own body there seem to
be plenty of boxes here to do that is
that what I'm supposed to do I don't
know but I've already lost one of the
ladders so I can't imagine that that
would be the only way across due to the
fact that it's stupid it's gotta be up
there I'm gonna be wandering the halls
forever if someone said what I needed to
do in the comments for the last video
I'm sorry I did not read it because I
just got home and fired this up as soon
as I got home so I apologize if I'm
being an idiot which I normally am then
I apologize for my stupidity
however being as it that it may I
articulate that a positive being stupid
is its own reward
all right anyway so I don't know if
there's something to do with these
ladders but it can't be a coincidence
that there's just ladders lying around
all over the place I mean there had to
be a reason that way out was probably
the way out come here
ah bagger oh it's so slow when you're
carrying it oh god it's so slow oh whoa
ladder whoa whoa buddy whoa seriously
calm down there brick all right there
was nothing up there are boxes though so
I'm gonna assume that it needs some sort
of stacking this this this this uh-oh
Oh what are these pallets for or I can't
even go through the door oh oh ah oh if
I put these pallets or if I put the
boxes here okay this is gonna be really
bad engineering but yeah oh God
rotate it flat like that put that there
well with just it like that and then
take the line or oh my god I'm gonna get
it I'm not gonna get it oh my ha ha
there's no way that I'm gonna get it
aha oh you can't beat me puzzle I'm too
ingenuitive nice
lordy it's stuck okay oh good golly
okay stop freaking out ladder and just
go up in the hole thank you and that'll
do a little more a little better angle
there
ah-ha ah-ha Oh No
get back up there haha oh oh it doesn't
let me grab it ah whoa red herrings all
over the place looks like I'm not gonna
be able to get break with the game out
of this is there some hidden under these
pallets maybe
oh haha
[Applause]
okay what was that all about I can't
exactly open it what uh I did wool
what's going on ha ha what ha wha
I don't even uh yeah uh I can't open it
it's not gonna open
I need like a hammer and chisel maybe it
doesn't open it's just kind of wait
crank crank okay all right maybe there's
a handle and chisel in the other you
know over here or maybe we could use one
of these hammer doodads a screwdriver
maybe I don't know I'll bang it on in a
couple of times and see what happens
couldn't hurt I guess huh nope okay nope
that a shovel yeah that's it I don't
know what's going on so obviously I'm
stuck haha oh but this is obviously the
solution that I do not know how to solve
so uh yeah if you all want to kindly
explain it to me and excruciating
explaining like I'm - okay just think of
me as a two-year-old or of equal
intelligence it's explained to me like
that so thank you all so much for
watching I'll solve this puzzle nenek
one click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye-bye
easy hey hey hey
I'll try
Oh
[Music]